sur le pelouse du stade pierre de
coubertin jeune garçon on en a déjà
parlé sur notre antenne fabrice zinedine
zidane
on est allé le rencontrer hier il est
tout ému encore zinedine zidane
difficile de s'exprimer pour lui ça va
toujours trotté dans la tête
un pic de marseille c'est d'abord c'est
ma ville cmcc c'est tout mais mes débuts
et je pense que que c'est bien quoi moi
c'est le match aller déjà au stade
vélodrome
khan avait réussi un exploit gagner 1 à
0 ouais c'est un exploit et c'était
étonnant mais tout début c'était même
une troisième match 4e match et c'était
vraiment je vous dis à la fin une
c'était vraiment un super pour moi et
pour et pour tout le monde et j'étais
très content d'avoir gagné a lancé alors
cet après midi retrouvailles avec
l'olympique de marseille
avec
zidane qui a mûri déjà qui a marqué un
but extraordinaire face au football club
de nantes
c'est extraordinaire non mais faut bien
que je marque quinze jours et puis c'est
arrivé contre nantes suis très content
alors à quelques heures de l'entrée sur
le terrain de pas peur et de tous ses
coéquipiers
l'olympique de marseille c'est toujours
le même relief qu'il avait lorsque
zinedine zidane était à 70
c'est toujours le grand club c'est
toujours le club en temps réel c'est
toujours le club taurin c'est toujours
le club où sékou c'est qu'on voudrait
bien mettre les pieds mais je pense que
c'est un rêve qui est qui qui peut pas
trop se faire et puis et puis voilà quoi
alors là c'est un adversaire là quelques
heures de retrouver les marseillais
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête que
comment on est mais je veux dire que
déjà à trois heures le coup d'envoi je
pense que c'est déjà ça c'est déjà
madame atteint depuis depuis bien
longtemps
et puis et puis il va falloir il va
falloir faire comme tous les autres
matches
et puis et puis voilà quoi la famille
elle va venir depuis marseille mais je
passe bien qui va voir la famille
beaucoup même
et puis puis la famille bon de toute
façon il faut la mettre de côté pour le
match
la famille c
ça vienne tout d'abord mais faut penser
d'abord au match et puis la famille pas
trop pensé quant à l'or il faut penser
d'abord aux copains comment une tout
jeune garçon qui débute dans une équipe
de professionnels est accueilli par
exemple à nice cannes par des luis
fernandez par des pierre dréossi par des
michel dussuyer et autres blessées
certaines de toute façon je pense que
tous ces joueurs là sont passés par là
avec avec un joueur d'expérience
à leurs côtés et je pense que pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose et comme
ils ont vécu ça je pense qu'ils vont le
le le faire transmettre
pour l'instant ça se passe bien avec eux
j'ai pas de problème et j'espère que ça
continuera
l'avenir de zinédine zidane au delà de
ce match contre marseille c'est quoi
déjà promis on est un petit peu pensé
non pas trop pour l'avenir parce qu'il
faut d'abord prouver bien des choses
vous prouver à plusieurs matchs il faut
se remettre en question mais l'avenir ça
vient comme sa vie et puis il faudra le
prendre au jour le jour
alors il n'y a pas encore de contrat
professionnel de signer dans s'est
étonné déjà professionnel à 19 ans
portes à partir de quand tu joues à
partir de là quand on joue en
professionnel
je pense que même en n'étant pas
professionnel un centre dans la problème
professionnel mais
[Musique]